all right Teresa
Teresa where are you from I'm from Los
Angeles California South Central yes
South Central
tell me about your family your mom I
interviewed the other day
my mom she was originally from Las Vegas
they moved out here with her grandmother
because her mom died at 16.
so they moved here to Los Los Angeles
and
um
they had
some good times but then I fold some bad
times too
we all lived with my great-grandmother
which is my mom's mother mother
so it was a lot of people we were in a
two-bedroom apartment and my mom had
four kids
my grandmother had her daughter there
my grandmother had her daughter's
husband there
so it's a a whole family living in a
two-bedroom
apartment I'm rlt so um
growing up
we we were treated well we weren't
abused or anything like that
it's just that uh
my auntie she got into selling drugs out
of my grandmother's house
so
um
long story short that
right there really made a hard impact on
my grandmother because she was old
so when her house got raided and we had
to move out
we didn't become homeless or anything it
was just really really hard on her
because now it's Financial stability and
everything that she's worried about for
us not for anyone else she's just
worried about
you know the kids in the house are they
going to have anywhere to go or anything
like that so we moved to Somerset
but when we get to Somerset everything
kind of like turned evil like everything
was so bad my aunt she went right back
to the selling crack to people
me my little sister my little brother
and my sister Brittany she's my older
sister and
she got into drugs really bad at like 15
16.
right after she had her first baby she
was like on it and
um I remember her and her boyfriend
always up
always up in the middle of the night
doing things
rumbling around the house looking for
things to sell or to steal I had to have
my own room on lockdown because of my
mom
she would come in the room and she was
still whatever she can just to get
whatever she came from my auntie that's
how toxic it was in my family
where you can go right next door to your
auntie in the same house
and get it like
I didn't understand
how we were going to learn from these
people you see I'm saying like how could
they teach us life
but when you're a kid you look you look
up to this so
my mom my sister they were on drugs
really heavy then we moved in my Aunt
Beverly which was actually on drugs too
and she used to really help my my mom
and my auntie and my grandmother around
the house like you know take us to
school do office uh school stuff with us
because my mom was
so messed up and sleep or just out doing
Lord knows what
and
couldn't go to school you know she
couldn't come to school that's how bad
she was doing drugs
so
we had all these people in our house
my my stepdad it was like a whole family
like a whole
tribe a clan we're in there with three
bedroom stacked up on each other now
that I have a life I'm 14 I have a life
I have a boyfriend my sister has her
boyfriend there
my mom has her boyfriend there my little
sister's dad is there it's so much going
on in that house it's ridiculous
I really praised my grandmother because
she wasn't our grandmother she was our
great grandmother and she saw what
we were going through as children like
she still was there
every day just paying the bills she was
doing her like I praise her I miss her
so much but I learned a lot from her
patients kindness doesn't matter what
people do in life you know drugs wreck
people life but she kept going
so I got my strength from her your mom
was your main parent at that point or my
grandmother was our Guardian so she was
probably our main parent but my mom was
there she was in our life but she wasn't
parenting
she wasn't you know she was like more
like my best friend than a mom yeah you
know the drugs changed that yeah the
whole dynamic don't they yeah where she
couldn't even parent her own children
she'll help me with some homework but
then she'll get distracted and she'll
leave it be and then Beverly would have
to step in and help me that's how she
stole clothes
on Christmas from my little brother
to go and get crack
like she used to steal from my
grandmother's safe all the time like
they used to have fights in the house
because my mom will steal
Brittany will steal they don't care
about anyone else so me I had to be the
bigger sister
I had to take care of Yolanda I did her
hair I made sure she went to school
everything
Joseph same thing go to school we'll you
know go to practice
me and my stepdad Willie we would help
my grandma do things I had to help my
grandma pay rent before
at 14 15 years old you know just
hustling selling T-shirts or
selling ecstasy pills because that's
what life I knew you know what I'm
saying I knew I could sell xcc or some
weed to get some money
and that's what I did
I went there that far to get money so
when I got
what I needed and
I gave it to my grandmother
whatever money came to me I gave it to
my grandmother to put on bills because I
knew my mom
was stealing so I would just give my
money to my grandmother
we would all get together try to help
her as much as we can
but my mom with her drug habit she goes
to jail back and forth so you got
Brittany in jail you have my mom in jail
so
my mom gets out one time I'm gonna tell
you a story my mom gets out
and
her boyfriend was messing with some lady
in a wheelchair
uh and
when my mom got out my her boyfriend
came back to our house to live
the lady in the wheelchair did not like
it
so she comes to our house and threatens
to kill everybody in the house like
really early in the morning like we had
to call the cops on this lady but the
police never really came they didn't do
anything she just rolled off
she told us she'll be back to kill all
of us so we didn't think you know being
in the South Central L.A and you know
you think you're hard because you're you
know you're a fighter and you and she
thinks she's hard and it's just too much
she comes back
okay she's on her way back first of all
because we're outside
hanging out
and all we know is the guy that was on
the phone with
her
or him they were on the phone together
the lady on in a wheelchair I think
Britney said they were on the phone he
yelled out said that someone needed help
at the corner of our street
so we run down there and we try to help
our friend that needs help but come to
find out it was all a setup
to meet the lady at the corner
in a wheelchair and she just like pulled
out a knife and stabs my little sister
like right in front of me my mom's there
she's screaming but moral of the story
is
we lost our sister because my mom
couldn't parent right
like I think like if my mom wasn't on
drugs
my little sister would be here
if my mom wasn't
being um
what they call a crackhead
my little sister will be here today you
know I'm saying now that I have eight
kids I have to be hard on her I have to
tell my mom
no you can't can sometimes and see them
no you cannot come over here because you
start drama or you steal or
and this is what we have to do we have
to come and visit her because we can't
let her in the house it's so bad she
she tries and she tries and she tries
but it's like the devil is running after
her ever since she was 16.
and like
I just pray for her strength I guess
because that's all you can do for people
is pray and try to be there as much as
you can
like I said my mom is my best friend
and I know she has it in her but
it's the surroundings
it's the people that are around her that
don't want to help her all they want to
do is help her get high yeah
so they can get high with her you know
and it's not right when you're downtown
and they say you have all these
resources
I think downtown needs a little more
a little more help it's it's too bad
down there it's
it's a virus
like you can get the drugs On Any Corner
you can get whatever you need anytime I
try to tell my mom to come to the house
and take showers and eat and you know
play with the kids outside all that
but
and your sister your little sister
passed away yeah she passed away from a
stabbing
that lady really stabbed my little
sister in front of me and didn't even
know who she was
she knew me
she knew I was Denise daughter but she
didn't know who this little girl was
you know and for her mom to have a knife
on her too
they were actually coming back to our
house to really harm us like we didn't
even think that was even possible like
you know you know how someone threatened
you and don't keep their work we thought
it was like that like okay nothing's
gonna happen we're gonna go pick up our
little ones from school
and get on our you know dinner night or
whatever
no it didn't go that way Yolanda came
home from school we all sat outside and
chilled we were outside with a bunch of
friends it was something about that day
because everybody that lived there that
we knew was outside
so my mom's in the house and she's doing
her thing or whatever but when we got
that phone call
it was like something else because
Yolanda like jumped up like no that's my
friend so let's go down here and check
on her so I walked with her I went with
my little sister down to the corner
after that we didn't see anyone but the
lady in the wheelchair rolling herself
with her mom actually pushing her and
then she had her cousin and her auntie
with her so we knew
we said what did my little sister said
someone called my mom but when we turn
around my mom's right there right behind
us like it was crazy because the lady
just walked up and Yolanda was like
hello Triana
where is your daughter is everything
okay and she just stabs my sister I
thought she punched her
then when she came back and she had that
knife in her hand and I saw blood in it
I was just like she stabbed Yolanda like
is this really happening like I had to
hold my little sisters in the body and
alone
and a lung well your lung is on your
side how old was your sister she was 16.
16 in his 10th grade playing basketball
and varsity
straight A student everybody loved her
everybody she wasn't evil she was very
understanding
very funny
she could dance rap
try to sing
but that girl was everything to us and
after we
lost her my grandma felt ill on cancer
which she fought since 73. and the
cancer this time spread it into her
stomach and then to her brain and she
just slowly died a year after
like
everything just fell down
I moved to Vegas with my boyfriend we
have eight kids together
and all I do is just hope my mom can
just
love these kids like she
tried to live us
she tried I can really say she tried but
what did you learn from this whole
lifestyle with your mom and your family
I learn no matter what goes on you these
people still my mom still needs someone
my mom still needs someone to uplift her
to love her for who she is not what she
does she is still a human being
okay just because she chose the wrong
word bro doesn't mean that I have to let
her go she's not dead she's still here
she's a living human being she has to
eat sleep and shower just like everybody
else on this Earth just like if someone
had an auntie down here on Skid Row or
or homeless in any other state just be
there for them they need a warm blanket
they need a warm hook
because they feel lost we don't ever
know what they're feeling
so don't judge them on what they do
judge them on who they are so
everybody go through battles everybody
I'm going through battles
you know and I don't put them on
everybody but everybody has a battle we
just can't leave them hanging like this
life is
and somewhat together you you're married
do you have a kid you have eight kids I
have eight kids and their dad is in
their life he is
amazing because who else would
stare out with so many kids nowadays
right but
he's great with them
I have a 16 year old he loves basketball
I have a 15 year old he loves basketball
they were both in high school and want
to try out
um so I'm rooting for them
my mom I'm just glad she's still here to
even see them grow up
to be wonderful because that's what
they're going to be
at the end of the day you're a great mom
thank you I try to be
I really do
would you say you're who you are because
of your family supporters yes for
fighting yes despite everybody's despite
of everybody's ups and downs just be who
you are be true and life goes on so some
drugs have never been something you've
dabbled in never I don't do drugs
because I see how
they have tore up my family it tore my
family up you know watching my sister
die in my arms
yeah I smoked some weed after that but I
did not go and do any drugs because
I've seen how people just lose their
whole soul and life over it you know
like I couldn't even see myself stealing
from anybody to get that like so not
that person I just
haven't went that way never have
Teresa thank you so much for coming in
and
thank you for the question a little bit
of your family's story your story thank
you I wish you the best of luck with
your kids thank you so much your mom yes
her too I split them all in there all
right thank you all right thank you